vimos a un presidente que ha gobernado
con un populista no no es tanto los
temas no son tanto enfocado en los
resultados sino en mi personalidad como
que es el masaje que va a arreglar todos
los problemas tuvieron las personas que
votaron por el presidente camps una
esperanza que han pasado de un hombre de
negocios supuestamente iba a ser algo
diferente a la política que hemos visto
en décadas los eeuu pero
desafortunadamente no fue así
lo que hizo es pues dividir más el país
insultar la imagen a nivel internacional
ha disminuido incluso los aliados
muchos de ellos han mirado a otros en el
mundo para para liderar por ejemplo la
de la política para américa latina pues
muy transaccional
al contrario no se vio cómo vamos a ver
el beneficio mutuo de un futuro para
mejorar las relaciones en la región
entonces esa división esa fricción
constantemente la inestabilidad
creo que el efecto al final del día como
estamos viendo ahora lo que ha decidido
el pueblo